the New York Post this week reports some
major breaking news you are basically a
crackhead and so am I it would seem
everyone is a crackhead the world is
full of crackheads which on second
thought might not come as news at all
though the reason may be a bit of of a
surprise it turns out that if you really
enjoy eating potato chips and if you
struggle to stick to the serving size of
the nutrition label then you are an
addict and of course everybody struggles
with that because frankly the serving
sizes are a joke if you look on the back
of your bag of lazed barbecued chips it
will tell you that the suggested Serv
size is like one chip per person per
week but if you struggle to keep your
consumption down to that level you might
as well be shooting up heroin according
to the science the New York Post reports
the news with this headline quote ice
cream and potato chips are just as
addictive as cocaine or
heroin
research that's according to research
research says that reading on can't put
down that bag of potato chips science
says it's not you it's the junk food
ultr processed foods or upss are are
just as addictive as nicotine cocaine or
heroin experts say and more than one in
10 people are hooked a new analysis of
281 studies across 36 different
countries have uncovered that a
staggering 14% of adults are hooked on
upfsi that UPF uh think sausage ice
cream biscuits soft drinks sugary
cereals have previously been linked to
cognitive decline cancer psychological
distress and even an early death the
analysis was led by University of
Michigan Professor Ashley Gearhart who
previously created the Yale food
addiction scale by applying the same
criteria that experts use to diagnose
substance addiction the criteria
includes uncontrollable and excessive
consumption cravings and continued
intake despite potential negative health
effects quote the combination of refined
carbohydrates and fats often found in
upfsi additive effect on brain reward
systems above either macronutrient alone
which may increase the addictive
potential of these Foods Gearhart and
the study's authors wrote in their new
findings published in the
bmj well we're then told that scientists
want a cigarette style warning label on
processed food cautioning the poor
addicted helpless consumer that the ice
cream he's buying is unhealthy and won't
help him achieve his weight loss goals
this is necessary they say because the
food is addictive just like heroin and
cocaine which is of course why our
streets are riddled with homeless bum
bums whose lives have been destroyed
because of their junk food addiction you
know the stories you know first a guy
buys a pack of Oreos and next thing you
know he's robbing a Coldstone creamy and
stealing the ice cream not the cash in
fact they even made a movie about a
man's plunge into ice cream addiction it
was called uh reum for a cream which is
a joke that I saw on Twitter but I wish
i' thought of myself anyway this is a
real issue is the point uh that's why
junk food withdrawal can be so severe
you know you go to your pantry find out
that you're out of Pop-Tarts then you
start sweating you have chills a fever
you begin to vomiting you're on the
ground shaking having a
seizure many people have died from
Pop-Tart withdraw you know because it's
just like being addicted to heroin
exactly the same I recently read a story
about a woman who turned a prostitution
just to feed her Pringle addiction
Pringle prostitutes they call them on
the streets Pringle tutes in fact is the
word you can find them on the same
street corner as the doughnut dealers
selling Black Market crispy creams to a
bunch of strung out junk food junkies
again this is all very real except for
the fact that it's entirely made up and
we've talked before about the modern
propensity to avoid personal
responsibility and deny Free Will by
turning everything into an addiction
there are many madeup addictions that
these uh these days but none of them are
as absurd as food addiction okay I'm
just going to tell you right now food
addiction is not a thing you are not an
addict you're just a glutton and despite
what psychologists who want to
medicalize every human Vice or virtue
might claim gluttony is not the same
thing as addiction
now how do they justify inventing this
food addiction concept how do they know
that food is addictive I mean how do
they distinguish someone who eats junk
food because it tastes good and they
like it from somebody who eats junk food
because they have a medical
addiction well there seem to be two
reasons typically given and the first is
the bit about reward systems in the
brain an article in Healthline about
food addiction puts it this way when
acting on Cravings the brain gets a
reward a feeling of pleasure associated
with the release of dopamine the reward
is what cravings and food addiction are
all about people with food addiction get
their fix by eating a particular food
until their brain has received all the
dopamine it was missing and this is how
it always goes right anytime somebody
wants to justify a new newly invented uh
addiction or mental illness they talk
about brain reward systems and dopamine
and so on and they expect us to just
accept it because it sounds super
sciency but if we use our minds we might
start to question this logic and for one
thing your
brain is is supposed to have a positive
chemical response to food we are wired
that way for a reason mainly so we don't
starve to death um junk food has lots of
fat and sugar which are things that your
body needs and craves and that's why
that's why people like to eat it because
it has your that's why your body rewards
it you have a your your brain uh gives
you a pleasurable chemical response to
those things because you need those
things now it's true that junk food has
too much fat F and too much sugar and
the wrong kinds because they're all
processed or Ultra processed apparently
but your brain responds positively to it
anyway because it tastes good The Taste
is pleasurable and that's why people eat
more of it than they should it's really
not any more complicated than that okay
we don't need a bnch we don't need 300
studies into it why do people why do
people like to eat potato chips I can't
understand it why do they eat why why do
people eat chocolate chip cookies why do
people like to eat cake because it
tastes good that's why they eat it
that's it that's the only reason end of
discussion in fact this is the essential
reason why people do every bad or
unhealthy thing that people do they do
it because it gives them pleasure they
do it because of the brains reward
systems that is the fundamental carnal
motivation that lies behind literally
all bad self-destructive behaviors so if
this is a reason to call junk food in
addiction then all bad behaviors are
addictions anything that a person does
that they know they shouldn't do but
they do it anyway because it feels good
is now in addiction so everything from
eating a bag of Doritos to
procrastinating on a school assignment
to calling in sick to work when you're
not really sick to uh robbing a bank or
having an affair all bad things big and
small all of them are addictions people
do them because they derive some kind of
pleasure from doing them if they didn't
derive pleasure from them they wouldn't
do
it they do them because in health lines
phrasing they get a feeling of pleasure
associated with the release of
dopamine okay it's not people talk about
dopamine like it's some sort of magical
Elixir oh there's dopamine so that must
mean it's some kind of medical thing no
that's it it's just you like it that's
all it means since the overturning of
roie Wade the left has completely lost
their minds making abortion their
official Sacrament meanwhile pro-life
efforts which are now more important
than ever are booming despite the
narrative pro pro lifers have not gone
away they've increased the number in
fact as one of the largest prif
organizations in the world no one's in a
better position than 40 Days for life to
to end abortion state by state 40 Days
for life is changing hearts and Minds in
the most blue pro-abortion states where
it is most necessary with 1 million
volunteers and 1,500 cities 40 Days for
life holds peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities you can help their
volunteers fight ongoing legal battles
to protect free speech for their
volunteers by giving a tax deductible
gift of any amount at 40 days
forlife.com that's 40days forlife.com if
this is reason enough to justify
classifying food as an addiction then
it's reason enough to justify all Vice
all sin all bad habits all bad choices
as addiction the same logic applies to
all of them with no
exceptions now we'll be told that
there's a difference though here because
um an addicted person is uh is so
enthralled by the chemical reward that
they can't help themselves a different
Healthline article on food addiction
quotes a psychotherapist who says this
if you can't stop yourself from eating
something overeat or if you find
yourself being secretive about eating
something or even have a withdrawal such
as feeling sick or having blood sugar
and
that is an
addiction if you can't stop yourself it
says well how does that work is there
some kind of mystical unseen Force
compelling you against your will to
stuff a chocolate chip muffin into your
face the guy going back for his forth
helping at Golden Corral can't stop
himself he has no Free Will at all what
is he possessed is he inhabited by some
kind of fat demon who loves fried
chicken really what do you mean he can't
stop here are some things that I can't
stop doing okay I can't can't stop being
six feet tall I can't stop being someone
who was born in
1986 um I can't stop obeying the law of
gravity these are all things I literally
cannot stop doing no matter how hard I
try does the Golden Corral buffet fall
into this category for some people is it
like gravity is it an inevitability is
it a thing that they that exerts control
over them so that while they're walking
to the buffet if you tried to talk to
them you wouldn't they'd have this
glossed glazed look in their eyes and
it's like there zombies walking towards
are they like moths flying into the the
you know the porch
light no of course not I mean they might
look like it and act like it but that's
not really what they are the food addict
can stop eating he can eat healthier he
can put down the fork he can put down
the tray he can put down the bag of
chips he can he just doesn't want to
he's not forced to eat he just really
really wants to eat and he does the
thing that he really really wants to do
even though he knows he shouldn't
because he is weak and he has very
little self-control he could have more
self-control if he put us put effort
into it but he doesn't feel like it it's
a character flaw it is a moral
defect one of his own making entirely
there's nothing medical going on here
except his
hypertension there's no medical
addiction though there's no overwhelming
compulsion that overrides his Free Will
so why do we really have this concept of
food addiction where did it really come
from
well that same Healthline article that I
mentioned earlier uh provides the real
answer the chief medical and clinical
officer at something called the eating
Recovery Center is quoted as saying this
quote in my experience some affected
people find the term food addiction
validating empowering and useful for
their
recovery there it is food addiction may
not be an accurate concept it may not be
true but it is validating it is useful
it is
empowering why
because it makes the Glutton feel better
about his gluttony by pretending that
it's not his fault it gives him an
excuse he's not the one in the Dairy
Queen drive-thru that's his addiction
his addiction is doing all that his
addiction is to blame now he gets to
drink the milkshake without any of the
guilt though he still gets all of the
diabetes because he can't Pawn that off
on his addiction especially because it
doesn't exist and that is why food
addiction is today cancelled hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there